olessa
hello I'm Anna Monson Creager I come
from Argentina and I'm taking a German
course near Heidelberg right now today
I'm free and I'd like to look at
Heidelberg come with me
oh you need look heidelberg castle let's
go up that's a weave
oh the Heidelberg Castle is a rune
I mean if I seen Andy I find it
fascinating to be here I think if you're
quiet you can really hear that past in
this place from here you have the best
view
let's take a picture
I've heard there are hiking trails on
this mountain which is called connect
stool I really like nature
so here we are
yeah young-looking what I like about
Germany is to walk in forest like this
the trees grow so high it's incredible
to look towards the sky and hardly see
it it's lovely
after all that walking I finally found a
bench good but it's not just any old
bench hello Hans cuando shredded chicken
when I was young my mother often told me
jokes in German and there was always a
hands so it's the only name that ever
occurs to me hello Hans what's this an
aviary and there are Falcons let's go in
it's spectacular
I'm feeding the birds
marvelous well I'm going to rest a
little now I shall I hope they will sell
down there we have the neckar river
wouldn't it be a good idea to take a
boat and see the city of Heidelberg from
the water let's go
what's been missing so far on my visit
to Heidelberg is seeing it from the neck
arm the view is spectacular you can
appreciate the colors of the houses the
flowers
it looks the girls are diving
we're not this is a good way to end the
day in Heidelberg I hope you've enjoyed
it and that you come and visit
Heidelberg yourself because it's a
beautiful city